hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're on Borderlands 2 today
because the new DLC commander Lua the
fight for sanctuary has just went live
today and it's around 1:00 in the
morning as I'm recording this so I
wanted to go over a little bit of the
story of what's happened and kind of get
everybody up to speed and seeing as I've
been playing Borderlands 2 for a very
long time and I've been enjoying the
series for a very long time I thought
I'd kind of give you guys my perspective
of what I think is going to be happening
with Borderlands 3 how this connects to
Borderlands 3 and seeing as this happens
to do with stuff after Borderlands 2 I
thought I'd just kind of share with you
the whole story just in case you're
confused and some of my thoughts for the
after credits and stuff like that this
is always like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe here for new my Twitter and
discord will be in the description down
below and let's get started so as I said
this is going to be a story of the DLC
and what the ending means as well as
kind of who Hector is and how he even
came here in the first place and what
his origin story is so let's get started
first off the DLC is gonna be free and
is live now so if you haven't got it
definitely go grab it and if you're
wondering if it's good or not it's free
just try it yourself but you start by
going to fight for your sanctuary which
is a new place on the map and then cuts
through a cutscene this takes place
after Borderlands 2 so we start after
the fight with handsome Jack and are
just guarding the vault key until an
army invade sanctuary this map is the
most important scientific discovery in
all of human history and Mordecai is
using it as a coaster after defeating
them the army starts throwing gas at all
of the civilians turning them into these
mutant creatures which are new enemy
types that we haven't fought in the game
yet and the head honcho whose name is
Hector right the base and traps you
luckily Louis manages to teleport in
time before you guys get killed but now
you are stranded oh so does this
continuing further you can find a camp
this camp is led by a bandit named
Vaughan who is actually the same Vaughan
from tales of the borderlands who is
amazing because that game is absolutely
phenomenal and I love Vaughan and his
whole storyline from that game so I'm
really but they're adding details of the
borderlands story into this game is well
really nice touch but after defeating
everyone in clearing the camp Tana says
that you need to go find some samples
for testing to figure out what the hell
this disease is and what's going on with
this gasps and what is even happening
just to get a clear of just what to
next basically from what we knew at this
point is that Colonel Hector wants a new
Pandora and he's going to be starting it
with sanctuary and he's going to be
using this gas that he calls the
Paradise gas and he's gonna be using the
vault key to mass-produce the gas and
basically wipe out the entire planet
using us as his test subjects but after
she tells you to go to the doll abandon
mine but you end up meeting with
Mordecai first and his new bird talent
but then he gets infected crop-dust and
to make matters worse you can't even
open the gate because they've been
reinforced and at one point a big in
fact it actually comes along towards the
backburner area which is where you
reside for basically the whole point of
the dlc and when i killed him I dropped
a rainbow tear weapon which is the
newest tear in the game now and it is a
TD or gun but it's not the throw and
explode type it's more of the spinning
shoot which is from Borderlands through
so that's a nice little nod to what
we're gonna be getting in the future for
that new sequel and also has this little
rainbow tint on the gun I'm not sure if
that's for every single rainbow weapon
but it is a nice touch nonetheless but
after turning this question you finally
get to do some side quests and I highly
recommend doing the SCOOTER one you get
from moxie right afterwards because not
only do you get to learn how scooter
died spoiler alert he died on a rocket
and tells the borderlands but you get to
find some important magazines Ellie
becomes the new catcher right owner and
you get a legendary skin for your car
which has scooters logo tattooed
basically all over it and you can jump
off a ramp while wearing it
10 out of 10 best quest in the entire
game
going back to the main story you arrived
in the boroughs filled with sandworms
which is the only way to get to the
Hyperion moonshot as recommended by
Mordecai as he's sitting on a table
clutching for his life then at this gate
you meet the first boss
JK is brick with brick at your side you
punch into the Hyperion base but wait
you're using a super big cannon to
destroy a door but no one knows how to
use it
yes tiny Tina is also back for the DLC
as well doing her objectives you reach
one part where you must get a Power Core
and you finally get to meet the first
boss Saturn's brother
Uranus because gearbox noticed how much
we love Saturn and decided [ __ ] it let's
add another one and I cheese the
everliving [ __ ] out of this boss after
dying 12 times and realized that hiding
and shooting was probably the best thing
to do since that's what I did for Saturn
so I did that and if you're wondering
did he actually sit in the back with an
infinity pistol for 20 minutes shooting
Uranus in the shoulder yes I did after
Uranus is finished pun intended
you go back to Tina and blow up the big
door
going back to back burner you find out
that it won't work and you need a blood
sample from Morty so you slap him and
get his blood afterwards you had to cash
as his lab who is the scientist of this
dlc besides Tanis and also this is the
same Cassius from Tesla borderlands as
well so we got two characters from that
game a billion new pandora soldiers and
spores and [ __ ] later you finally make
it to cash his lab where there's a quest
in the mines as well with some lore but
we'll cover that at the end and it
actually ties the whole story together
but once you get to his lab you import
Morty's blood sample and realize that it
doesn't work so caches ask for one final
request and that is to kill him he's
actually not too hard I managed to kill
him with the hellborn build with Krieg
fairly well which is actually surprising
because Krieg is terrible against bosses
but after the boss flight you push
through the paradise sanctum arrive in
sanctuary where you finally meet and
defeat Hector but Hector doesn't go down
easily once defeating him you have to
rush over to crazy URLs to grab his
iridium and holy [ __ ] there is so much
of it after giving it to Lilith she uses
all the power that she can muster up and
she blows up sanctuary destroying Hector
with it but right before she does Hector
says that she must destroy the key to
destroy him but as we know from the
ending cutscene that's actually not the
case the vault key is still there and is
just sitting on the ground in the sand
so Hector was so partially wrong and
that is the DLC now let's talk about the
other section of the story which is
basically who is Hector Hector was a
colonel who worked in a group called
scarab 191 and he also mentions how he
never went to Pandora and talked about
other places like Eden 6 presumably
another planet within the solar system
but then he was tasked by command to be
miners on Pandora and find some minerals
he didn't like the idea but he made do
with his position in his group but to
his luck one of them ended up finding a
shiny Rock which I assume is iridium
seeing as they didn't have the volca at
this point and we're pretty ecstatic and
they were promised promotions new land
and tons of money as well but sadly the
company turned their backs on them and
created a cave-in people went mad but
Hector tried to maintain the peace but
it didn't really work I believe he was
one of the few survivors as well and he
said no matter the cost he will uphold
his promise even though they broke
theirs and get his group to peace and
happiness they deserve which is kind of
wholesome and it makes me feel bad for
Hector a little bit he's just a man
helping out his friends after he was
lied to but after the credits like I
mentioned there was a cutscene of the
vault and the dirt will the states as
well that they need to leave Pandora to
find all these
volts before the bad people do and get a
hold of them but she's going to be
staying here in in Pandora so that she
can basically rebuild the Crimson
Raiders but that's not actually the case
because as everybody leaves Ellie
basically convinces her saying that that
wasn't really the real reason why you
did that and Louis admits that it wasn't
basically she is going to try to find
the volcanoes that it's in there and of
course we saw the cutscene we still know
that the vault key is out there
somewhere my assumption is that it since
it's still just laying there the new
twins in Borderlands 3 maybe have picked
it up and are now rating vaults at their
leisure this could be totally wrong but
seeing as the two of them are the two
antagonists and basically the whole
thing of what we're doing is making sure
to cover up all the vaults so that the
other bad people of Pandora and the
whole universe don't get their hands on
them this probably makes the most
logical sense to me but as for what's
gonna happen in Borderlands 3 we'll just
have to wait and find out yeah guys that
was the whole DLC Borderlands 2
the commander Lilith fight for sanctuary
it was an excellent DLC and honestly I
thought it was pretty nice there was a
lot of nice send offs like scooter and
such and caches which rip him he was a
really nice character and tales of the
borderlands and seeing as we haven't had
a dlc for the game in Gears it was
really nice to finally go back and play
something new and it was really
refreshing and I'm surprised that they
didn't actually [ __ ] it up but it's
gearbox they normally don't [ __ ] up
anything with Borderlands 2 or any of
the borderlands games so I'm very
satisfied of what they pulled off today
and of course they're gonna be keeping
the game fresh with new rainbow weapons
that we haven't even discovered yet we
all thought that we found all the
legendaries well boom we have an entire
tier [ __ ] to go through we have a couple
more levels we have eight levels indeed
and of course even if you haven't hit
op8 you still have all those levels to
get to as well yeah let me know how you
guys enjoyed the DLC like I said I
thought it was really cool it was a bit
hard playing his Creed Krieg is one of
those characters that is really not that
great in terms of raids and bosses in
general so that was a pretty tough one I
had to end up using the melee build at
the very end of the game I switched from
I had hellborn the entire time but then
I went for a more BETT buzz ax rampage
type build at the very end to defeat
Hector it was just a very
pain-in-the-ass boss fight but I managed
to get it done anyway yeah let me know
how you guys were enjoying the bosses
and let me know what kind of weapons you
guys got in the comments below it love
to know any new rainbow weapons that I
would be expecting while go grind after
this video is done yeah I like to be if
you do enjoy guys subscribe here for new
like I said let me know in the comments
about what you think that end
means what you think it's gonna happen
I'd love to know your thoughts my
Twitter and discord will be in the
description down below and my two most
recent videos are gonna be popping up on
screen if you guys want to check that
out they're gonna be Borderlands three
related and with that hope you guys have
a gross turday and drove the rest of the
DLC if you haven't beaten it and peace
out enjoy
[Music]
you
[Music]